hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the top 10 most
controversial opinions about the Harry
Potter series these of course are
opinions in which fans have long since
battled over since the release of the
novels throughout the making of the
films and now more than 10 years later
and since I love a good debate let's get
to it 10 Barty crunch Jr was hogwart's
best data teacher for those of you who
may need a little reminder Barty crch Jr
was the son of British Ministry of magic
official Barty crch Senor he was also a
loyal Death Eater who was accused of
torturing Alice and Frank Longbottom to
the point of insanity using the
cruciatus curse after Escaping The
Wizarding prison of aaban and being held
captive by his father for the better
part of a decade bti Jr was well rather
insane and yet he somehow managed to
believably impersonate one of the most
skilled AAS of the day Al Madi I moody
in the role of Hogwarts defense against
the dark arts professor and not only did
Barty Jr succeed in his impersonation of
madii he was also actually really good
at teaching so much so that some fans
argued that Barty Crouch Jr as madii
Moody was actually the best defense
against the dark arts Professor that
Harry and his classmates ever had he
went Above and Beyond in the things he
taught the class and consistently seemed
to go out of his way to mentor and teach
Harry skills such as helping him
practice ice overcoming the imperious
curse a skill that Harry later uses in
the face of Voldemort's attempt to make
him bow of course this opinion is quite
controversial considering Bary Jr was
not only insane but a literal murderer
those who oppos this opinion offer the
idea that perhaps Barty Crouch Jr was
just a rather skilled wizard which
doesn't necessarily translate to his
ability as a professor he also performed
the three unforgivable curses in his
classroom which was not only illegal but
an endangerment to his entire class nine
Draco Malfoy didn't deserve his
Redemption Arc particularly in the
movies Draco Malfoy is given a story arc
that attempts to redeem his inexcusable
Behavior earlier in the series while
some fans believe this Arc is completely
Justified Draco was just a boy who' been
raised in a Prejudice family was under
the tutelage of seus Snape who was
rather spiteful himself bullying
students and all that the other side of
this argument claims that Malfoy is
simply an arrogant git one who would
have murdered Alber Dumbledore had Snape
not stepped in the contention in this
opinion stems from whether you believe
that Malfoy was truly an evil wizard who
did nasty and unkind things to others
for sport or a misguided young man who
eventually tried to do what was right
eight Harry Potter was kind of a weenie
Harry Potter the boy who lived the
chosen one he was an incredibly Brave
young boy who embraced the fact that his
well got turned upside down at the mere
age of 11 but was he also kind of a
selfish boastful jerk in many fans
opinions he most certainly was these
fans need only to point to one of
several scenes in existence in which
Harry is wallowing in his own misery and
pushes those closest to him away yes he
was under extreme amounts of pressure
but he also never really seems to check
in on how his friends are doing with all
the chaos that surrounds them each and
every year at Hogwarts seven Harry and
Hermione should have been a couple for
years and years fans have fought over
whether herione and Ron belong together
or if Miss know at all Granger should
have ended up with Harry especially in
films min Harry do seem better matched
if you're a book fan however you know
that the movies do a poor job of
representing Ron as a well-rounded
character in comparison with the novels
even so there are still a large number
of fans who ship Harry and Hermione in
any case it all comes down to one
question really how does that tent dance
scene between Harry and Herm in Deathly
Hallows part one make you feel queasy
and awkward or super pumped based on
your answer you know which side of this
controversial opinion you're on six
zerus black was a poor Godfather to
Harry to many fans of the series Sirus
Black was the type of Loving Family
Harry never had growing up a stark
contrast to the neglectful derley but
was he really all that great at being
Harry's Godfather this opinion has fans
quite divided as there are those who are
Fierce supporters of Sirus and his
positive impact on Harry's life on the
opposite side of this coin however we
have fans who bring up some valid points
for starters zerus never made contact
with Harry before breaking into Hogwarts
as a fugitive from asabin you'd think
he'd want to try and warn his former
best friend's son about the dangers of
Peter pettigru parading around as a rat
in his very dormatory or perhaps attempt
to let him know he wasn't a mass
murderer coming for him and after they
finally connect he really wasn't around
all that much for Harry obviously he had
to keep hidden due to his fugitive
status but you'd think he would have
been a touch more present you know other
than the odd conversation through a
magical fireplace five Neville long
bottom should have been the chosen one
this well-known opinion is rather more
of a theory than some of the others on
this list there are many many fans who
believe that Neville Longbottom was in
fact the real chosen one that Professor
siil trone spoke of in her prophecy and
even if he wasn't maybe he should have
been I mean Neil really came into his
own in the end so is it not crazy to
think that he could have made a more
heroic version of the boy who lived in
my opinion he certainly would have been
a less whiny version four Dumbledore
should have killed Tom Riddle as a child
the controversy over this particular
opinion stems from the fact that
Dumbledore would have had to kill a
child however fans argue that if
Dumbledore suspected just how evil Tom
Riddle was and how much Terror he would
bring to the world as Voldemort
shouldn't he have eliminated him as a
child when he had the chance three ala
Dumbledore was more evil than good it's
no secret that Alber Dumbledore spent
his youth feeling rather self-important
something he made clear in his
declaration to Harry I was gifted I was
brilliant I wanted to escape I wanted to
shine I wanted Glory I was left with the
the responsibility of a damaged sister
and Wayward brother I returned to my
Village in anger and bitterness trapped
and wasted I thought as a young man with
his prideful Spirit alus also developed
a close relationship with G grindewald
who went on to become one of the darkest
Wizards to have ever lived alongside
grindlewald Dall plotted how the two
could unite the three Deathly Hallows
and subjugate Muggles this Alliance
inevitably led to an argument between
the two and albus's brother Abba forth
which resulted in the death of his
ailing sister
Ariana then there's the fact that he
went on to Mentor Harry Potter as a
child knowing the whole time that the
boy would need to sacrifice himself and
die at the hands of Voldemort in order
to overcome and defeat him the argument
against all that of course is all the
good that he did after his choices as a
Young Man and the fact that he was
simply trying to protect the entire
Wizarding World from Voldemort
exchanging the life of Harry in order to
save many two Snape was a hero one of
the most divisive opinions of the
franchise is whether or not SRA snake
was a good person a hero for everything
he did to help Dumbledore the Order of
the Phoenix and Harry himself despite
his actions that helped take down
Voldemort however there's always the
other side to this argument that he only
did so for his own selfish reasons that
his love for Lily Evans was not enough
to redeem his qualities as a bully and
an incredibly spiteful and rather cruel
wizard one the movies were better than
the books there are fans who will only
ever read the books ones who will read
the books and watch the movies and those
who will only see the films no matter
which group you ask however people will
always have a fairly strong opinion on
which of these series is better and
likee with many film adaptations the
majority of fans seem to say that the
books are better they included more
details more backstories and plot lines
but then there are other fans who are
adamant that the movies were actually
the better of the two and with that
we've come to the end of another video
where do you sit on these controversial
topics did I miss any controversial
opinions about Harry Potter please share
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel also be sure to check out
the content on Spotify as well as extra
content on my second Channel Harry
Potter Theory extra until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
live